Saka is a problem with the sciatic nerve
the sciatic nerve is the longest and
largest nerve in the body if you look at
the width of your thumb okay that's
usually the width of that nerve uh where
it comes out and it comes out of the
lower back and the sacrum okay and
there's five nerves that form this one
stic nerve and when we have a problem
with that nerve that's called sciatica
now there are some great wonderful
stretches that you can find on the
internet I've done vide on that which
are great for stica but the problem is
what happens later in the day or the
next day when it comes right back so
today we're going to talk about what we
can do to actually correct this problem
um without having to use medication but
you still want to do the stretches as
well all right so what do we know about
cica well we know 90% of the time it
involves the disc and the dis is
basically it has an outside and it has
an inside the inside is like a little
jelly donut and what happens when the
outer part of that disc uh gets weakened
some of that uh jelly can kind of
squeeze out and that can put pressure on
part of the nerve roots that make up the
stic nerve and then you have pain either
in your butt or it travels down the back
of the leg all the way down to the foot
or the outer part of the leg and
sometimes it's not just like severe pain
it could be a numbness it could be a
burning could be a gnawing like a deep
kind of irritating type sensation the
reason I'm even doing this video is that
I found this condition that was
interesting to me because I haven't
really heard about it before um and that
condition is called Milo neuropathy myON
neuropathy what does that mean that's m
y e l o Milo well that word means the
marrow of your spinal column and that's
composed of like a lot of different
nerves that come up and down the spinal
column and then they come out and
neuropathy means some type of damage to
the Nerf so this condition myON
neuropathy is really combination of a
problem in the spinal column and the
nerves that come out called the
peripheral nerves and this can give you
a lot of different uh nerve problems
including a lot of sensory nerve
problems like I just mentioned like the
burning the gnawing the numbness severe
pain and even weakness in the muscle
because these nerves connect with
muscles but what really interests me
about this condition that I never heard
before is that it's a copper deficiency
most of the time or a vitamin E or fola
deficiency but the majority of the time
it's a copper deficiency so I started
looking at Copper in relationship to the
stic nerve and I found some fascinating
information number one there's all sorts
of different types of therapy that use
copper for inflammation and pain like
copper bracelets copper patches copper
cream and even a a brace that you could
wrap around your upper hip area that can
cover the stic nerve at lease the origin
of the satic nerve and it's laced with
copper and a lot of people are reporting
amazing results with that and we don't
really know exactly why copper can help
pain and inflammation and I'm talking
about just topically putting it on the
body I mean something could be actually
potentially kind of being absorbed maybe
but maybe not but I know copper is a
very conductive um metal and so maybe it
does something with the electrical
fields that are out of balance in the
area of pain I don't know and there's
not hardly any research on this at all
but that doesn't mean it doesn't work I
mean the amount of people that are
reporting great relief from this I mean
I'm talking about skeptical people is
quite large so I'm not just going to
wait for the next study or someone to
invest in the study to prove that it
might work because it's a very uh
lowrisk non-toxic relatively inexpensive
thing that anyone can do and even in
ancient Egyptian times they use copper
copper bracelets copper jewelry
for their pain inflammation and
arthritis and since we're on the topic
of arthritis the Arthritis Foundation uh
said that there's no validity to using
these copper bracelets or even magnetic
bracelets so you know you want to try it
because whatever they say not to do
usually is going to work very well
simply because of who funds these
organizations right drug companies I
don't know for all I know they probably
started these some of these foundations
now that's using copper externally but
what about copper
deficiency what does that have to do
with anything well it has to do with a
lot because it's involved with quite a
few different enzymes and what of the
enzymes that create a big impact in Saka
is the enzyme that uses copper as an
essential co-actor for building collagen
and connective tissue and guess what is
your disc made of collagen well yeah 75%
of the outer part of that disc is made
from collagen so if you're deficient in
collagen could it be possible that you
can have a weakness within the disc now
copper is also used in enzymes that
involve nerves okay the nervous system
nerve transmission and even myin that
protects the nerve so a lot of things
start lining up uh in relationship to
looking at a copper deficiency and
potentially having a sciatic type
problem I know other people might
develop like carpal tunnel syndrome when
they have a copper deficiency as well so
copper is essential for
collagen and I've done other videos on
collagen before and talking about how
important vitamin C is is in making
collagen but guess what uh if you look
at nature copper makes a part of that
vitamin C complex so we have copper for
collagen and connected tissue we also
have copper for the nervous system
certain parts of your brain have very
high levels of copper dopamine this is
why there's usually a copper deficiency
when a person has Parkinson's involving
dopamine and we know dopamine involves
the nerve muscle connection and issues
with that copper is also involved in
making energy helping you sleep also in
making melanin which helps prevent
graying of the hair it's also involved
with red blood cells and we're going to
come back to that in in a second it's
involved in the formation a bone and is
an
antioxidant so how would someone become
deficient in Copper well a lot of people
are deficient in Copper from various
reasons uh one is they don't have enough
copper in the diet which I will get into
like what foods are high in that but
it's it's really high in the shellfish
and organ Meats which two things that
people don't consume a lot of also
athletes are usually low in Copper
because they're doing a lot of physical
exercise that use up a lot of energy
that require an increased demand of
copper and especially if they're doing
exercise at higher
altitudes because that involves uh
strain on the red blood cell but the
more exercise you do the more copper
you're going to need and you can imagine
if an athlete is really working out and
they're not eating right they can end up
with a copper deficiency and then have a
weakness within the connective tissue or
collagen and um create a a problem with
the tendons ligaments muscles and discs
now also if you take a lot of zinc okay
without the opposing mineral copper you
can create a copper deficiency as well
also if you take a lot of iron you can
deplete your copper uh there's many
different reasons why enriched flour
products as in the breads the pasta type
foods can deplete copper fluoride from
your tap water uh definitely depletes
copper too much vitamin C but mainly in
the form of ascorbic acid sometimes
people do certain remedies where they're
taking like certain like maybe maybe two
or three or four grams of scorc acid
that's going to deplete your copper as
well a lot of sweating can deplete your
copper because copper can come out
through the sweat too much uh suntanning
can actually deplete your copper because
of the connection with melanin melanin
requires copper and then you also have
stress and even too much of the
precursor DHEA which actually is a raw
material to make cortisol too much of
that or too much cortisol can deplete
your copper even when you have a lot of
potassium without these Trac minerals
like copper that can worsen the
deficiency and of course you have
distilled water as well you're going to
create a deficiency of all the minerals
with distilled water you have to put
those back in also we have high levels
of niin can deplete copper to a certain
degree so as I'm going through these
it's just an important thing to remember
anytime you take a lot of one nutrient
without the others in the complexes
especially if you're not getting food
sources you can create imbalances
gastric bypass you're going to have a
tendency to be deficient in not just
copper but other trace minerals if you
eat too much sugar you can actually have
deficiency or even too much coffee and
alcohol can do it and even aspartame as
an artificial sweetener can deplete your
copper but I think there's one
additional thing that's very very
important and I I looked at this as well
um probably people that have caka also
have a genetic issue with uh copper
being absorbed creating a deficiency
even though you're taking normal amounts
that's related to kind of a topic I've
been deeply studying on DNA it's called
polymorphism that's a mutation or an
error in the gene that can leave you
deficient in certain things well I found
two different genes that if you have a
problem with that you most likely will
have a copper deficiency and then that
can relate to other issues as well and
the study that talks about that that
Associates a higher level of getting
carpal tunnel syndrome which is pain in
the wrist as well as uh compression
fractures because copper is involved in
the bone because certain part of your
bone is made out of collagen all right
so all this is very interesting but what
can you do about it well you have
options um one really good remedy might
be to do a search on Amazon to find one
of those copper braces and when you see
the copper braces it looks like it
supports the hip but it wraps around the
Ox right where that stic nerve comes out
and it's in the upper thigh and it's
lined with copper that might be a really
good solution to give you temporary
relief as well as these other products
that have um copper patches or even a
copper cream but it's also important
number two to make sure you're getting
enough Copper from the food and so the
food that has the most copper would be
beef liver it could be any liver but
liver in general uh number two oysters
number three shellfish number four dark
chocolate of course get the sugar-free
number five cashews and number six meat
in general like grass-fed beef now
number three if you're going to do a
copper supplement okay which is not a
bad idea because that way you can
actually correct it and by chance if you
have this genetic weakness you're going
to have to take a little more than just
the bare bones amount so what I would
recommend is I would
start with 2 Mig of copper per day and
slowly increase that over a period of
one month to 20 milligrams and you can
do the math on that but every several
days you take a little bit more and more
and more until you achieve 20 milligrams
so you might need these higher amounts
to make the change necessary for your
disc to start healing up and your
nervous system to start healing up and
then after a month you can play around
with it reduce the dosage
see how you feel if you do good then
stay at a lower amount if it gets worse
take a little bit more and then over a
period of maybe three or four months
maybe kind of wean it down to like 2
milligrams a day and see if that's all
you need but the point is I wanted to
put this focus on this connection
between copper and sadica it's very
interesting but it doesn't invalidate
the necessity to do these stretches now
because of the censoring and the
suppressing of the algorithms on YouTube
becoming more difficult to find my
content and there's a lot of content
that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side and if you have not
seen this video you should check it out
it's very very
important